deux chroniqueurs y asseoir autour de
cette table ont passé la soirée ensemble
moi je veux tu
sais qui c'est delphine et guillaume
bien sûr la sorte aller dîner en plus
vous nous avez chauffer comme on vient
vous avez posté une photo sur les
réseaux après que les vue c'est toi dire
qu'il a postées lancé delphine
lorsqu'il sait que derrière ça ça fait
parler tout le monde même après s'il ya
une belle voiture derrière voiture de
certaines cigarettes de batman la
session qui étaient garés dans la
gentille
on dit rien et vous avez vu l'article
publié début j'avais promis le royal
monceau qui est un très bel hôtel ils
ont fini dans un petit restaurant
italien l'amateur des années ça va
se savoir delphine à la machinerie
qu'est ce que tu as pris
[Rires]
finn déjà dans cette photo ce qu'il faut
voir c'est le premier plan c'est la
complicité
être
la complicité amicale cadre des amis
entre presque deux membres de la même
fratrie pas trop non plus
[Rires]
et pour moi comme un cousin on a fait
une saison vous avez dit roger qui coule
à
flots et voilà il va augmenter leurs
voitures très proches parce que j'avais
petit la voiture
nous sommes arrivés au restaurant
c'était très très bon alors qu'elles
resteront avec vous amener le césar west
ham en italien ah ouais je vais très
bien
on a parlé de la vie apparaît grand et
de nos vies respectives
il faut quand même dire comme sur les
réseaux sociaux les gens se sont
inquiétés parce que delphine tout le
monde sait que vous êtes avec roger et
moi je suis rouge et je pense que leur
combat au restaurant alors on lui
envoyait une fois oui on lui envoie en
série à face à va rien dire sur george
sherill
[Rires]
[Musique]
le but l'ignorance à kong ou
non dit button lewis qui a conduit ces
défis qui a coincé génial mais c'est
terrible alors plutôt fait conduire vous
bas c'est sympa ce qui est exceptionnel
c'est que grâce à guillaume j'ai roulé
pour la première fois à paris parce que
je n'ai jamais pris la voiture apparaît
mois alors qu'elle était le plus fort
dans cette soirée s'est débrouillé dans
farine et avec lui ma tête est fort très
fort tout était très bien s'est il alors
à
la balance pas inquiété mais il avait
privatisé il avait pu accéder à l'entrée
des studios non il a un énorme
authentique n'avait fait dégager tout le
monde allait l'amener voitures de luxe
et amener voitures de luxe forte il y
avait plus personne autour d'eux d'où la
photo et il a fait monter delphine dans
la voiture de luxe pour l'impressionner
alors ça c'est faux qu'on nomme
guillaume je verrais tu es blessé tu es
sûr de lui c'est vrai ou pas
jouez vous avez amené pour des titres
c'est vrai ou pas c'est la tienne c'est
la mienne a pas d'accord l'assiette
jazzy conduit pas j'ai pas le permis
non c'était c'était un dîner
professionnels mais bien sûr j'ai évoqué
avec delphine de nombreux projets dont
celui de la pécho
malheureusement pas le jour non mais
c'est ainsi c'est sûr mais c'est un
dîner amical évidemment c'est en tout en
toute amitié non mais c'est un truc
super fort quand même parce que ils
l'emmènent au restaurant dîners il ya
une location je pense que c'est parce
que sa voiture une location s'en fout la
voiture de luxe et ils alex conduit arte
rend compte
qu'à paris on est une voiture ou kiki et
guillaume sciard fois sur l'année qui
conduit à la nature nantes un chauffeur
un ami qu'elle allait monter derrière
mais
vous n'êtes pas invité isabelle par
exemple que de placer la voiture
malheureuse non je vais inviter avec
plaisir
[Applaudissements]
bon alors et après ils vous en
raccompagnant en amont il a la bombe
ayem compagne après pour rentrer j'ai dû
prendre un über parce que du coup il y
avait que deux places et les rentrées
avec exactement parce que j'avais dîné à
trois noms mais il a dû appeler son
copain pour la nature passer n'importe
quoi votre truc victoire
lundi les gourmets
gens qu'il est qu'il achète une voiture
d'un tel prix sans avoir le permis faute
mais je suis pas capable de conduire en
fait voilà j'ai loupé cinq fois mon
permis je ne suis pas capable de condat
mais c'est là qu'il est extraordinaire
ils vont au restaurant avec la nana il
passa sa part lee discute et au moment
de la ramener chez days inn enfin
vétérans
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
amical
jalil a été conduit lundi
je l'appelais une voiture ça mais c'est
vrai la prochaine fois peut-être que tu
choisisses un autre cadre parce que là
il ya soit ea c'est glam alors
évidemment delphine magnifique la
voiture très bien et derrière tu as
quand même mcdonald's et au tac aux
décorum je suis pas sûr c'est peut-être
un autre cadre en fait alors ça c'est
terminé commandant vous êtes rentré en
taxi après un choc avec celle entre que
son pote exactement tous craignent aussi
d'être j'aime assez l'idée très bonne
soirée dans la bonne humeur on a passé
une bonne soirée très bonne soirée avec
ce titre j'ai passé une très bonne
soirée c'était très sympa et le
spaghetti comprend chez cargill jim est
tous d'accord j'avais des paysannes et
belles filles d'ailleurs dit roger de
tout ça il effondré il effondré
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ils ont pour une fois tu as mulhouse où
il ya personne
roger salah pas énervé non mais il est
ravi revient à dire ça alors ça leur
avait causé
[Rires]
tout à fait amicale et donc voilà donc
y'a pas de soucis et pourquoi est ce que
aujourd'hui en 2021 quentin
guillaume louis parce que lui c'est un
prédateur
devrait passer une bonne soirée c'était
très bien et en plus guillaume tu peux
le rappeler aux gens est devenu vegan
dont il y avait gagné
s'est foutu de sa tête toute la soirée
mais les dégâts
man show pied la
cdu kervegan j'ai lu plein de
commentaires sur instagram il y en a qui
aiment ou ya marqué la belle et la bête
je sais pas comment le prendre la tête à
un peu de
toi mais
un dessin animé culte quand même oui
c'est moi c'est mon idole moi c'est
devenu mon idole d'aller au restaurant
de ce bar est comme ça et là tu prends
une photo le mec il au téléphone il en
marianne s'est
mis tout le monde d'accord on peut
passer à un autre sujet terminé rideau
c'est moi de mercy ans par le maire
silva